with the chairman of the House Judiciary
and oversight committees are now making
a request for a second special council
that formal request was made about an
hour ago with the Attorney General jeff
Sessions in a Fox News exclusive tonight
the two chairmen are with me now Bob
Goodlatte from the House Judiciary
Committee and trey Gowdy from the House
Oversight Committee and gentlemen thank
you for your time here
chairman Gowdy you sledder States
matters have arisen what's changed what
changed for me was the knowledge that
there two dozen witnesses that Michael
Horowitz the Inspector General would not
have access to so your options are DOJ
investigated themselves they can't do
that because of conflict of interest let
the Inspector General do it now I'm a
big fan of my coral woods but he has no
jurisdiction over witnesses that if
either left the department or never
worked there so when I counted up 24
witnesses that he would not be able to
access where he to investigated yeah
only one conclusion that special counsel
who's on that list
everybody from Jim Comey - Andy McCabe -
rebecky my Sidney Blumenthal Cody
Shearer anyone who no longer works for
the Department of Justice over the FBI
State Department you may recall a couple
of weeks ago there was some indication
that State Department employees were
feeding information diffusion GPS they
would be outside the reach of the
Inspector General so anyone who's not
currently employee of DOJ Michael
Horowitz doesn't have subpoena poverty
there was a report that McCabe was a
leaker for the Hillary Clinton matter is
that true I don't know
and Horowitz will be issuing that report
and I have a lot of confidence in him
then I think bill he's a straight
shooter and we'll see - chairman
Goodlatte you said earlier today about
the FISA Court specifically the process
was abused how well it was abused by a
gathering of information from a very
suspect source not disclosing that
information to the court and in my
opinion getting authority to look into
the background of an American citizen
life on questionable circumstances and
that is a very serious concern you know
the FBI is
America's premier law-enforcement
organization every day thousands and
thousands of great men and women keep us
safe investigate crime prevent terrorist
attacks but several people at the top of
this organization have engaged in
activities that are questionable and I
think that in order to set the record
straight clear what is going on at the
FBI and make sure this does not happen
again we need to have an outside special
counseling mr. let me read from your
letter in part on screen you write
there's evidence of bias trending toward
animus in your letter among those
charged with investigating serious cases
there is evidence political opposition
research was used in court filings
there's evidence this political
opposition research was neither vetted
before it was used nor fully revealed to
relevant tribunal and quote do you have
evidence the Department of Justice was
spying on the Trump team during the
election that depends on whether or not
you consider Carter phase to be part of
the Trump team he was an advisor to this
so to the extent that he was an advisor
absolutely this whole FISA warrant was
on quarter page and and necessarily you
would also pick up conversations that
quarter-page was having with others so
the answer that question de facto is yes
when you will prove the warrant against
quarter-page mm-hmm do you agree I agree
its premise ton the idea that mr. Page
was somehow critically involved in
something that they wanted to
investigate and I think the case that
was built for that is highly suspect
what is wrong with the IG doing his job
there's nothing wrong with the IG doing
his job and I want him to go ahead he
has a couple of tasks in front of him
one is to complete his investigation
into how the FBI handled the Clinton
email matter that is separate and we
want that report out as soon as possible
because we know he's been working hard
on that he's looked at more than a
million documents and that should be
made public the Attorney General has now
tasked him with looking into this matter
as well but has as trey has noted he
can't do the complete job it involves
other departments of the government
do you trust the Attorney General I
definitely welcome the Attorney General
encouraging that aspect of the
investigation I think more needs to be
done and I think the way to do that that
helps the Attorney General the Deputy
Attorney General the Department of
Justice and the FBI is to take it
outside of those organizations so the
American people can see this properly
investigated those looking on the other
side of this may suggest that Congress
can go ahead and do this job what's
wrong with that idea anyone who's
watched Congress over the last 12 months
we leak like subs and us a week only
because I'm a member of Congress but
that's pretty common for this town yeah
it is but serious investigations don't
leave the executive branch
investigations whether it's your local
district attorney or whether it's Bob
Muller there are far fewer leaks from
Bob Mulder than there are from Adam
Schiff
so we don't have the tools we don't have
access to a grand jury we can't grant
immunity we can't compel testimony and
we're not we don't prosecute crime so
there are a thousand reasons to let the
executive branch or Special Counsel
handle this as opposed to Congress you
do know where special counsels lead you
start with a land deal in Arkansas and
you end up with a blue dress you have no
control over that you can set the
strictures of the jurisdiction if
Attorney General Sessions decides to
appoint special counsel he's going to
give a document that sets the
jurisdiction the only reason Bob Muller
can go where he's going now with manna
fort and others is because the fourth
Clause of that jurisdiction allows him
to pursue other matters that may arise
so you can you can limit the
jurisdiction in the four corners of the
document there was a suggestion today
that if the house flips in November you
would lose control of the issue is that
part of the reason why you're pursuing
it now Jana no I don't think we're going
to lose control of the house but I think
that control of this investigation has
to be done in a more orderly fashion
than you get when it becomes a political
football as this issue clearly has in
the House Intelligence Committee and
elsewhere in the Congress so we're going
to continue to do our oversight duties
to investigate but I think a more
thorough investigation that can get to
the bottom of the matter and do it in a
way that can result in the FBI's
reputation being restored and changes
that are needed to be made be made is
best done with the web minute counsel
when will you get a response in your
letter from the Attorney General we
don't know but we hope we hear from him
soon and we hope that he takes action
and that he does so in a substantive way
will you get an answer I don't know that
we'll get a formal answer the fact that
he doesn't appoint one I guess is an
answer he doesn't owe us a formal
explanation but I think it'd be wise for
him to give us one because I I think our
you know chairman Goodlatte and I do not
routinely call for special counsel I've
resisted to call in other cases this
fact pattern is unique and compelling
and I think you ought to really consider
it gentlemen thank you for your time sir
trey Gowdy Bob Goodlatte
thank you